I feel bad for saying this right but
people are doing this VR stuff right and
like women of all ages are getting
virtually graped and I'm just like take
it off your dang head like just throw
like what come on come on and everything
and I'm so sorry but okay I'm just gonna
say this not everything is grape
if you if you literally slept with
someone and then you felt bad about it
that doesn't mean that it was great and
so I just need to say that for the women
because y'all are saying that everything
is grape and if it was why didn't you
report it to the cops and why didn't you
go to the hospital and why didn't you
get the pill so that you could take care
of that possible
um I don't know if I can say the a word
on here but why don't you do that no
because you actually are just dealing
with the emotions of the fact that you
didn't want to sleep with that person
and then you consented to it because you
were drunk and they were drunk and then
now y'all got to deal with it so no not
everything is grape not everything is
essay and you need to just understand
that maybe you made a bad decision and
maybe you got to deal with it and okay
if I get drunk can I rob a store did I
not rob the store
did you not drink and drive right you
got in the car you drank and drive you
got in the car you got the DUI
so like that's the same thing you can't
you can't blame it on the fact that you
were drunk
like oh my gosh have you noticed how
women have an excuse for everything so
when I'm here I have this sign I have
this sign right and I'm like I'm going
around and saying look I think
abortion's a cop-out in most cases
outside of grape I think abortions cop
out because it's and they said they say
why right and I say because you're
you're asking you're bailing being
bailed out for your poor decisions and
they'll always argue with me they'll be
like well was it a poor decision I'm
like wasn't it good in
what
I did you know
the arguments end really quickly
whenever Pearl's like why are you
sleeping with men that you don't think
would be a good father like a threat
against post they're like you know what
Checkmate man check me or hear me out
and they'll be like well
my body's bad on birth control
well I mean learning cycle tracking I
don't know
no no there's there's Wade I want it to
be perfect like what do you mean you
want to be relieved with the burden of
giving birth and what you think like
you're just not you're not going to feel
funky at all like it's a medication like
you I like you gotta deal with it I get
it it gives you mood swings you feel
like crap okay but you don't you want to
have unprotected sex without getting
pregnant like or get married yeah or
they want to have multiple sex partners
in a month and then they forget who they
actually had sex with on that day if you
are having that many sexual partners
write it down on the calendar
like oh I had sex on this day maybe I
should uh pee on my ovulation stick and
see if I'm ovulating that day if you are
that concerned but that's the thing is
that no one actually so I've been having
this argument on Tick Tock because
learning about your body is apparently
not my body my choice apparently
learning about your body is like so
difficult like God forbid you have to
pee on a stick every day which costs
16.59 on Amazon to buy a pack of 50 pee
on the stick track your ovulation with
an app if you don't want to take birth
control right or get an IUD or don't or
abstain from sex or try condoms in the
pull out method like there are so many
there are so many methods of not getting
pregnant right and then they say to the
guys
right they say well if you didn't want
to deal with it he shouldn't he should
he should manage his sperm well you
should close your legs it's the same
argument so I don't get what the actual
issue here is if you don't want to have
a baby
like if you never want to have a baby go
get a hysterectomy that will be a full
like you will never have a baby after
that oh yeah do it if you that's what
you want right yeah I mean we tell men
all the time to get uh to get
vasectomies so here I have a question
for you too okay because I think like
this is mad weird so like there's the
whole you know Progressive women that if
you have a miscarriage they're like oh
like I'm sorry for your loss but then if
a woman terminates the pregnancy they're
like oh like that was her choice right
so what about mothers that because this
is a real thing that happened in real
life I I found out that um someone
someone uh I don't know obviously sent
me a message about this so they said
that the woman had gotten two
terminations of pregnancies had
miscarried twice and then kept the fifth
fifth baby right the fifth pregnancy but
it's like you'll see with these people
they'll be like oh like I love being a
mom it's the best job in the world look
at my baby and you're like what about
what about like the the other two like I
don't think women that terminate are
like as maternal of women as other women
like it it's it should I don't know like
I just have to get your guys's thoughts
because it's weird to me like how are
you gonna convince me that you love your
baby but it's like you love your baby
when it's convenient like they I think
they're kind of nuts you know that's
exactly what it is it's only a baby when
the woman wants the pregnancy if she
doesn't want the pregnancy it's a clump
of cells
if you ask if you literally that's what
it is I go it's a fee like sure it's a
fetus a fetus is a unborn human baby
still a baby
it's gonna grow and come out be a
perfectly healthy baby
so if you don't do anything like if you
don't do anything medically the baby's
gonna grow you're gonna survive and
everyone's gonna be okay right
but they want to take dangerous pills
they want to do like the The Hanger
method and all this other stuff to their
bodies cool do that and then you'll
never have a baby you'll never get to
the point like if you finally get to the
point where okay I'm finally get got out
of my delusion and now I want a baby
well you messed up all of that stuff
because you took too many abortion pills
um you got a DNC scrape too many times
and guess what your uterus has too much
scarring and you can't hold the it can't
hold a pregnancy so I'm so sorry but um
that's how biology works so these people
that are saying
um it's not a it's a clump of cells it's
this that okay
um go to princeton.edu and look up when
conception uh conception starts right
look up justfacts.org
the medical community the scientific
community
pretty much affirms that life begins
at freaking conception okay sorry I'm
Rebecca no I have a question and I'm a
mom and I'm a mom so this triggers me
more than anything we're like I have a
question I don't people always ask me if
I think the plan B is a form of abortion
and I don't have a good answer because I
I looked it up and it says it's not but
they said it can so I'm like I don't
know so plan B is basically all of the
birth control that you take in a month
condensed into one pill or two pills
however it is so
it's basically like the the biggest
birth control pill that you could take
that's what you're like that's what
you're taking you're taking like
basically all the doses in a month in
one take I don't know if they still make
two pills or one pill but
it's basically that so what is it yes it
could
oh my God you could say that it is an
abortion because you're triggering your
period sorry guys you're gonna hear
about periods
um period to come but also if you take
like actual
um like herbs you can also
induce your period to come to which a
lot of people don't know that
oh interesting I just I always get asked
that question and I'm like I don't
actually know when I'm out with my sign
well that's what I've been told it's
basically
it's basically
um the condensed version of all of your
birth control in one month
oh wow how does that sound good also
freely accessible ladies also the United
States Army they give you two plan B's a
year for free okay it's like fifty
dollars all right go get you one if it's
really that important crazy things
hearing stories of babies that are like
they're like this baby survived too plan
B's I'm like
oh yeah
also
also if you like if you're underage
because that's like where they're
telling people like they're telling
women oh like what happens if you're
underage if you're underage and you can
drink alcohol like you
you find ways to get alcohol and
cigarettes
I think you could probably finagle
getting a plan B okay I'm just saying if
you can if you can coerce people to get
you alcohol you can coerce someone to go
get you a plan B girlfriend you don't
need to go to the abortion clinic and
here's the other thing too if you're
tracking your period right if you're
tracking your cycle every month and you
have to you happen to have sex
um in that time right you can go early
where like the the six week some the
states have like the heartbeat bill you
can go
do whatever you need to do right because
you found out early because you were
tracking your cycle and because you're
writing it down and you know who how
many people you had sex with that month
like
that's more control over your body than
just saying well we're just going to
leave it up to chance we'll figure it
out
so you want to go
forty percent of women that have had
abortions have had two or more
yeah and and that and you don't know out
of the sixty percent what what
percentage of them are going to get it
in the future so it just seems to this
is what I would tell people on the
street I'm like it just seems to be like
a cop-out for poor decisions anyways
Ally go on oh yeah yeah so like I have
an extraordinarily long cycle like uh I
mean for most people it's like 35 to 39
days so like but but even so like you
can track it and like it's like six
weeks you like you if you're a woman who
like you get um you menstruate like
every two months or something like you
you would know right which you would
probably just have to take pregnancy
tests routinely if you're having
unprotected sex but I think it was like
six weeks go by and you're not like you
know
kind of weird I just I haven't I haven't
bled like what what do you mean like it
goes over your head like you just forgot
like you just like you're just not gonna
ask like how how many drugs are you
doing like how many how hard are you
partying where you're like it just never
came I don't know that's that's honestly
like what I ask all the time like how do
you not know
how do you not know even if you have an
irregular cycle also if you have any
irregular cycle go get that check that's
probably a hormonal issue that you
probably need more work to figure out
where why that is because most women
should have normal Cycles 24 or 28 day
cycles
um
so
figure it out stop like stop let's stop
normalizing irregular Cycles how about
that right there you go